[Music]
and is this fair news always though it's
never fair life's not fair facts
submitted by Bart vs. geo oh yeah
in what dough mmm yeah you I like to UFC
a champ Henry Sam who dough who no keeps
calling out female fighters for a match
Oh what what he just wants a punch a
woman then I'm doing it why this is your
world was a repeat offender
he just wants an excuse to beat women we
believe that's what I'm saying so he
calls out Amanda Nunez yes chef chinko
thank you me me Joe and Jill have seen
Amanda Nunez fight in real life she's a
badass
and we also know I didn't just mean
geoscientist Devoto fight I think he
just gets turned on but he just wants
some physical attention maybe he just
wants a buff ass TV in his face I like
that hot sauce hot sauce Valentina
oh yeah hopefully they're seducing each
other you know what's up they got the
smirk they both got a fighter she
imagine them facing each other right now
doesn't really even look like so Julio
he look like a WWE wrestler I know that
is a weird picture of them it doesn't
really look it looks like they
photoshopped the crown on yeah he does
have a big head though so here he is on
this is the video that he posted calling
out Valentina oops so I'm out here enjoy
my beautiful Sunday here in beautiful
Las Vegas but I gave my inner did my
phone just keeps blowing up because
that's somebody by name of Valentina the
[ __ ] Shenko is the most dominant
chapter in the world and guess what I
get a little jelly is you know what she
has to old and I want that goal
Valentina Shevchenko I have a message
for you
I'm looking to become the first
inter-gender ever seen that's crazy
[Music]
two-five tweeted looking for oh that's
that's illegal that's right that's right
that's a he said I'll be there right
after I finished polishing my gold medal
and belts okay I see that polish them
good then do their [ __ ] nowhere do
that okay I will
and that's why they're fighters and not
really good roasters I mean like did he
get away with the talking they just get
into fights well what are you doing
tweeting why aren't you polishing it I
would have called him a [ __ ] or
something come on jingle speaks English
oh so she just might not even understand
what Harry say polish or Russian or what
she thought she was talking [ __ ] like
that's a nice cat and pulling me like
Alma [ __ ] you up
Anna translate that is a nice cat yeah
but this it sparks an interesting
discussion about inter-gender fights
here this was clearly [ __ ] control and
dude but the thing that gives it a
little bit of that legitimacy but like
paws like possibility is that he's
challenging someone in his weight class
are they the same weight yeah so they're
both so he's a small dude he's small I
think this is the smallest one I think
he fights out 125 and 135 her also
fights out 125 135 so when she's saying
it it's not like a Mike Tyson that's
like 230 pounds challenging I'm like
another chick like he's he's saying
something
that is possible and he comes from the
wrestling world so he's an Olympic gold
medal medalist in wrestling and if and
if anyone knows anything about wrestling
in high school it's co-ed mm-hmm I've
seen girls [ __ ] out of dudes girlfriend
who was arrested in high school we had a
chick on our team and there was times
she would out wrestle dudes all the time
so it's not as far-fetched as people
think it is so they get to wrestle co-ed
in high school but you still have to
dance six inches apart
I've seen some badass chicks in high
school I've seen badass chicks in MMA
and kickboxing and all that so to me
there's one side of me that's like the
traditional side of me on like oh my god
I can't believe dude wants to fight a
girl but then on the same token knowing
that the MMA knowledge that I have a lot
of chicks their training partners are
dudes
yeah don't beat the [ __ ] out of a lot of
dudes so they're actually really good
so finding an inter-gender champ that's
actually a very interesting topic I mean
then being the same weight class made it
different for me that smells like oh
okay that sounds just like he's just
challenging somebody to size yeah you
know like okay what are you chicks think
about it what do you broads think about
this how you [ __ ] feel about this she
good for me because I come from this
world a little bit I've already seen it
happen so it's not too crazy I see
that's good inside and I'm interested so
I'm actually interested even when you in
class in your sparring and whatever they
don't go women stick with women like we
all yeah and why do they separate it in
college and stuff like why is it only
nice I don't know about wrestling in
high school I mean in college I'm not
super familiar with that what did you
get out of this though you know saying I
feel like lose-lose for him I think that
this is like a lot of publicity like
he's publicity person to be like the
first intragenic cuz this is not the
first time he's done it it's like being
man on the moon first to do it I guess
I don't know and he's understanding the
politics of what's going on right now
with like gender stuff I think it's I
think it's smart to you just made me
think of something right cuz like art so
our women mad at him for this or who's
mad at him for this because like really
this is him being mad whoa it's like
equal he's superwoman yeah so it's not I
can be like I want to beat up a girl
it's him being like hey we're on the
same look unless he's using the app to
chant like I want to be the ultimate
champ of everything yeah yeah so is easy
to woke or is he a troll that's exactly
what I was definitely she's up here and
I need to be I beat her to be the
champion or is he like or she's famous
let me piggyback off her and kind of
like see if I can be number two as known
as she is so she in the female fight
world she is probably one of the best
stand-up fighter like strikers in terms
of kickboxing like her her technique is
like is pristine so it's [ __ ] good
so like she's not like just some random
chick you know she's really really good
at striking well let's put it in the
perspective of Olympics right yeah let's
say if the Olympics just lifted the
gender rules and anybody can participate
no matter which gender I don't think it
would be fair for the ladies I mean just
because stats and scores you can see the
performance difference and the top of
the top and yeah then like yeah we won't
even have a chance to be in the Olympics
hmm so I don't know man it's kind of
hard to say and then you have another
whole camp that you know if you take
testosterone like females taking
testosterone in order to be you know
transgender and stuff or become the sex
that they believe that they are like
there's that whole issue too because
they're like you're not supposed to take
steroids in any sport but then they're
like well I'm taking it for other
reasons not for performance reasons hmm
so it's it's it gets really crazy I
don't know for me and I think for me
just just society whatever yeah well I
just what I've grown up with I think I
would feel uncomfortable even though I'm
like girl do you if you want to do that
like I would cheer it but I don't think
I could be a spectator
because I there's something makes you
feel worth it makes me feel
uncomfortable to see a man striking a
woman but how you know the man's gonna
win geo huh how you know the man
I said striking you put that what if the
woman just [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of
the dude would that make you feel
different well that's funny it what much
do with like I can't be a spectator
because then there's that possibility of
him striking back oh right and I just
feel uncomfortable watching that you
know I actually felt weird the first
time I started watching just women MMA
just seeing two girls going that brutal
bloody nose like boom like that kind of
stuff so weird it took me like a couple
of fights to like be able to like be
that violent with each other yeah it was
like a low at first it was a little
strange you know I'm saying you're not
really used to seeing that you almost
feel like like oh no like oh no please
don't do that to hold the card by Carla
Esparza
it's like lose-lose for him cuz like
like going with what you're used to
seeing it's almost like for him if he if
he loses it's like oh you got to be by a
girl and if you win it's like what the
[ __ ] you beat up a girl like I mean I
get publicity publicity that's true cuz
if the lady won and it's like good for
you especially in this time if she lost
it's like well I mean what do you expect
right yeah she even won because it's
like good for you you went on stage and
you fought your heart is yeah anything
for the lady that I might be like well
he let you in on you you couldn't strike
his heart that's rough
what's crazy is lose-lose for the guy I
mean if they want to be martyrs and then
they want to just change it cuz like
like you said it took you a few a few
times to watch it and like in order for
you to get used to seeing that maybe
like it should happen this way we're
like just true and then by the next
generation they won't see
so dainty and so weird like brutal II in
a fight yeah I think like so there's
always that argument that male biology
is more favorable in sports than female
biology but that's actually a sports
specific so when you look at super
marathon runners the fastest runner in
the world for super marathon which is a
hundred miles and over is a female and
she beat the second-place male by over a
day Wow it's just like sperm yeah men
are faster but then women last longer
yeah
so this chick like she is after she
crosses the finish line the other person
is even an hour behind it's a day it's a
super marriage like a 72 hour like
running session 48 hours running 100 200
miles so they're constantly running and
over the course of like two or three
days they might only sleep ten minutes I
know they're just constantly running so
with that type of with that type of
information on biology too it's like
combat sports is a combination of
endurance explosiveness but also a lot
of skill and technique so it's like and
you say women technique is it's way
cleaner than medicine from what I've
seen so I'm from two perspectives from
women's technique because in some
explosive movements they don't have what
males have like just muscle fibers their
technique is way more clean too they
don't rely on athleticism they rely on
the technique in the second thing even
in coaching females like for fitness
because girls don't have as much of the
Eagle as guys do they just learn so much
faster so you'll see like in both
lifting and combat sports guys they'll
learn something right and they'll
immediately go I don't think this
coaches for me and then they'll start
researching I don't know my coach is
doing it right I mean let me get three
other coaches to cross-reference and
they have this ego so they actually
stunt how fast they can go a lot of
girls when they learn from a person they
just go this this person is God to me
and I'm just gonna learn everything I
may just they go up so fast there's a
lot of things that make girls like
actually really good that I'm like I
don't know it might not be that clear
the whole title cards are really good
yeah guys can hold them way high up now
and again now it's louder
[Laughter]
[Music]